If a person has to eat or drink in order
to save his or her life, does that um
mean that they have to make up that fast
later on or is it accepted that fast?
If a person is dying as you say dying of
hunger or dying of thirst,
yes,
while fasting if he feels hungry and
thirsty and if he feels that if he does
not take something, does not take some
food or does not take some water, it
will damage some of his organs of the
body. If he feel his life is threatened
or may cause a major damage to some of
his organs, then if he breaks the fast
to save his life, it is accepted. Allah
will forgive him. But he will have to
make up for his fast after the month of
Ramadan is over. But if someone finds it
hard, difficult to fast because if he's
doing a laborous work or he's finding
difficulties, he's feeling thirsty in
this case breaking the fast is a sin.
But if he's really dying of hunger and
then if he breaks Allah I'll forgive him
but have to make up for the fast later